Họ khẩu xác gióan tìm, rồi tương sếp sông, tương bố ngày 6.8, tì lệ ông hộ tổng thủ miền đơn đơn trâm đã giảm xuống
có bà mi so phần trăm, mức thấp nhất kể từ khi ông đã đồ dự kiện tài.
Có số nơi giảm bốn điểm phần trăm sób y tổn trước, phản ánh sử dạ tăng lo ngại của công Trung về kinh tế và chỉ vì sinh hoạc.
Kết quả khẩu xác cho thấy chỉ có khoảng hâm hấp nếu phần trăm người được hỏi, tảm thành cách tổng thăm trăm sử li và nề chỉ vì sinh hoạc.
Trông khi tì lệ ông hộ chính xác kinh tế nói chung, giảm xuống còn 2 mi chính phần trăm.
Giảm tảy nghĩ dạ tăng khoảng 1 đô là Mỹ 1 ca. kể từ khi xung lột Iran bụt phán tối tháng 2 người áp lực lên người thư dụng.
Lên qua những tình hành trình sự chỉ có 3 mấy là phần trăm người Mỹ ủng hộ các cuộc tấn công nhạm và Iran.
Trông khi có 3 mối phần trăm bài tỏ hông đồng tình, khoảng 1 mối phần trăm sử người được hỏi cho sang,
cuối chiến sẽ kì Mỹ kếm ánh toàn hơn trong xác ánh.
Dù vậy, mất đồng hộ của tông thông trăm trong nội bộ đảng công hóa vẫn tương đối ổn định.
Hảo xác được thực hiện với 1 mi 2 người trường thành trên toàn nước Mỹ, với xác số khoảng 3 điểm phần trăm.
Theo Ấn tình Røy Tân, trong những ngày đồng nhận tì lệ ông hộ tổng thêm của tông thông thông đông nân trăm, là bố Mỹ bài phần trăm,
và từ đó, suy chỉ trung bình ở nước khoảng 4 mi phần trăm.